you're not going to believe this but
making a second key fob for this Chevy
Tahoe starts
right in here
[Music]
for your Chevy vehicle you're just
waiting for trouble one day if this
thing gets lost you find yourself locked
out of the vehicle
[Music]
save yourself a lot of head
ER Tom ski company and pick up that
spare today before you have a problem
we'll save you hundreds of dollars over
what the car dealership wants to charge
you I'm Mike with Tom's key company with
one working key fob I'm going to show
you how you can make a spare without
leaving home it's super easy we have
solutions for thousands of vehicles to
help you with do-it-yourself spare key
and fob programming come check this out
now I've got my existing one here this
one works for the vehicle here's the new
one it does nothing
first thing you got to do is from your
working remote fob
pull this emergency key blade out you
might not even know that existed this
high security blade fits right in the
door lock here
now you may be thinking how am I going
to get my new key fob blade cut so in an
emergency I can still get into the
vehicle if the fob battery dies your
vehicle battery dies well stick around
to the end I'm going to show you our
awesome Key by photo service
with my working key fob the key blade
out I'm going to take it I'm going to
set this inside the vehicle keep the key
with me and the new ones I want to
program now as I begin I want to tell
you a couple important things
you can make up to eight fobs using this
technique but you must have one existing
working fob that already starts the
engine you got to clear out whatever's
in this pocket the makeup business cards
any change you've got once that thing's
empty you're ready to begin if you have
more than one working fob be sure you
set all those inside the vehicle keep
the fob or fobs you want to program with
you outside
we're taking our working key putting it
in the lock turn it five times
counterclockwise one two three four five
check out what it says on the dashboard
ready for remote three
okay take our new fob
come back in this little pocket you're
gonna drop the key fob right there don't
press the brake pedal press the start
stop button once
pull this guy out the dashboard may or
may not display that it's ready to
program the next key fob press the
unlock or lock button once
this key fob is now programmed to
program additional key fobs at the same
time you'll repeat the same process put
the fob in the pocket
press the start stop button once
take the fob out of the pocket and push
unlock or lock one time
okay now you got to hold the start stop
button for about 12 to 15 seconds
3 4 12 13 14 15.
let's check all our fobs
the original one still works here's the
new one
boom it works too
let's make sure it starts the engine to
do that I'm going to get out of the
vehicle
and take both of these remotes out of
The View
let's try to start the engine with no
remotes in the vehicle should give us an
error
no remote detected
so let me grab our new remote
we've got the new key fob
let's start the engine
look at that fires right up beautiful
that was easy
okay let's get the original remote
let's make sure the original one still
starts the engine
beautiful that looks great
okay now for the magic for our key by
photo before you can program your new
spare key you need to get your keyblade
cut to match your existing key to do
that you can either run all over town
trying to find someplace to cut it or
you can add our key by photo key cutting
service during checkout it's super easy
Once you place your order
you got to pull out the emergency
keyblade get it flat on a table take it
out you're gonna hold the phone directly
over your key get three clear pictures
you'll upload those photos after
completing checkout on our website
so we can cut your new emergency
keyblade to fit your vehicle
it's pretty cool wasn't that easy
the Chevy Tahoe has two fobs
Tom ski company we stand behind all our
products with a full money back
guarantee you can't get it working for
you just let us know ship it all back
we'll refund all your money it's that
easy be sure you subscribe so you can
find this video again
and leave a comment let others know
about your experience go place your
order tomskey.com we're excited to help
you get a spare key for your vehicle